hard-throwing left-hander jesus lizardo
3-2 a 4-12
era pitched twice in the postseason last
year not very good against the white sox
in game one and game three in the
division series against the astros an
important key to the a success in 2021
rides on the talented left arm
of lizardo as he makes his debut tonight
for 20 21.
and here's michael brantley we've added
300 a year ago and last night he was
three for four with a home run
took a little bit off and he strikes out
brightly throws a breaking ball by him
good action and moving toward the
outside corner good numbers last season
for christian javier in the regular
season 12 games 10 of those starts and
how about that bottom line finished
third in american league rookie of the
year voting one out and nobody on for
ramon lariano the center fielder two for
four with the double on opening night
and lariano hits it out in the short
center straw coming in coming in
headlong dive in he caught it excellent
play by miles straw he got that just
before it hit the grass
and la ariano is the second out in
spectacular fashion there's the reaction
from christian here's
who was all for four last night that's
swung on hit to right center up the
alley long run for lauriano racing goes
into a slide can't hold it bobbles it
and then karam's over toward tama plays
it back
guerrielle goes to second he should be
at third with two out i'm not sure what
gurilla was thinking
but as lariana raced toward right center
going into a slide trying to cradle the
ball
and couldn't hold on it's a base hit and
now the astros with the two way have
runners at first and second so here's
maldonado right-handed hitter at the
belt here it is swung on it
off speed inside maldonado k is inning
over
so second third for the astros bregman
to the plate couple of extra base hits
in yesterday's game a double and a homer
bregman first pitch swinging sends one
to left field hit well all the way back
gone three run home run alex bregman
back-to-back knights alex has two home
runs in the first two games of the
season and it's three-nothing astros boy
he wasted no time first pitch
and a fastball belt high and bregman
turned on it he knew it right away fun
is back that's a good thing gosh that's
what they want to hear that's what those
guys want to prove too julie gurio will
lead things off for the astros 2-2 is
hit pretty well left field going back on
it is canna he tries to measure it and
it's out of here for guerrilla a moon
shot to left field and it's four-nothing
astros on guriel's
first home run of the season
and yuli pulled the hands in and up got
the hands above it and just got the
barrel to it that is not easy to do at
96 miles an hour two b's on first here's
brantley he's one for two doubled and
scored in the third this one into left
center field going back is laureato this
one's well hit it short hops the wall
altuve around third here comes the throw
altumi is safe at home play
michael brandley another extra base hit
his third double the season second
tonight and the astros now lead it five
to nothing for the first time the a's
making javier work now remote laureano
the a's trying to get something going
down five nothing drill to center
straw going back straw at the wall straw
cat get it bangs off the roll here comes
kenny around third top stage waving him
home
he will score it's an rbi triple for
l'oreal
the ball stayed in play for miles straw
couldn't get it
directly over his head
and for ramon that's his third hit of
the series yeah he could be a real pick
to click this year he looks great payoff
pitch to moreland with runners at first
and third the a's down five to one and a
fast ball is hit high in the air to
right center not very deep tucker
getting in position loriano getting
ready to tag tucker catches it here
comes laureano here comes the throw on
his short hop the tag is late floriano
is safe and the a's got another run
headlong dive by ramon is the difference
it's now 5-2 on the moorland sac fly to
right center field lottery over three
last night with a walk jet lara's last
hit i mean last hit not just as a member
of the athletics the last hit boom gone
september the 29th of 2018 because for
two years jed didn't play for the mets
so and the right-hander to the plate
swung on line back up the middle that's
the base hit olson up the second base
it'll hold there as straw plays it back
in so jed his first hit back and five at
bats as an athletic not christian javier
out of the game the 0-1 awkward swing
ground ball snared by abreu on the leap
no one's covering first he slides to the
bag in time to get lariano
what a play by brian abreu
guriel who is the only infielder on the
right side had gone toward the ball a
bray you lunged for it got it just to
the right of the mound race to first and
did a hook slide into the bag to get the
out so here's mitch moreland two on one
out mitch hits the ground ball might be
too charging correa tries to tag the
runner he gets chapman and the photo
first completes a double play and matt
lost his helmet fans don't like it
chapman gets to his feet appears to be
okay and the enemy is over correa
treated chapman like a speed bump
basically top of the seventh with a 5-2
lead so the batter now with runners on
first and third is kyle tucker tucker
with runners on first and third trying
to get a run home he won't hear unless
this ball is dropped somehow by andrews
he makes the play here comes altuve
trying to score he does he does he
scores on a pop up to short how did he
do that jose altumi gets a sacrifice fly
for kyle tucker on a pop-up on the
infield you have got to love this if
you're an astro fan one out of one on
and here comes chad pinder swung out
belted deep left and the a's are back in
it
pinder knows it it goes a mile into the
second section of seats past the out of
town scoreboard
home run chad pinder they're first for
the asia 20-21
he scores jed lowry and now the asia
trim the deficit to 6-4
but lorianno is
being lifted here for
tony kemp
ramon went
diving into first base in his last
at-bat just speculating
that's a fair point
olson's 90 feet away and steven
piscotti's going to bat for mitch
moorland and steven will make his first
appearance of the campaign
big chopper that'll get a run home
perfect always going on contact that's
correct so olson comes in to score
piscotty with the rbi ground up and now
it's six to five
and bregman's gonna be intentionally
walked to bring up the lefty tucker
shot through the middle the diamond
infield in gets past andrews one run
scores here comes bradley he'll score
astros take an 8-5 lead on the 2rbi base
hit by kyle tucker
[Applause]
little bouncer olson will flip with his
gloves safe at first base is straw runs
scores it is 9-5
the gold glover matt olson didn't come
up with it cleanly
[Applause]
goes the other way bregman's there the
throw to correa covering and that'll do
it the astros winners tonight 9-5 coming
off a win in the season opener